hello everyone and welcome to
today's webinar researching early
detection of
ovarian and endometrial cancer using
high sensitivity genomic
my name is mark garner i'm with agilent
technologies and i'll be the moderator
for today's event
uh today's event is presented by
elaborate and it's brought to you by
agilent we'd like to encourage you to
participate today by
submitting any questions you have during
the presentation
to do so just type them in the ask a
ques question box and then click send
we'll try and answer as many questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have any technical issues you can
also submit those in the same box
i'd like to welcome our speakers dr lucy
gilbert
from the department of obstetrics and
gynecology
and the department of oncology at mcgill
who's also the director of the
gynecologic cancer service at mcgill
health center and dr giannis ragusas
who's head of genome sciences at mcgill
and the genome quebec innovation center
um you know today
especially just after asco we know that
early detection of cancer is so
important giving patients that can
a chance getting it earlier and i'm
really excited with the presentation
today because i think
that really uh addresses that question
directly
so with that uh dr gilbert i'll turn it
over to you to begin your presentation
thank you for that presentation i am
lucy gilbert
i'm the director of gynecological
oncologist
on gynecologic oncology at mcgill
university health center
i'm extremely pleased to be doing this
presentation
it's on a genomic path test for the
early detection of ovarian
and anomaly cancer it's still in its
research
phase but i'm pleased to say that we are
in
quite a late stage of research and
development
and i'm grateful to
all our supporters and funders for
helping us get to the state
so what i shall cover today
is the clinical aspects because i am
predominantly a clinician
what is dub gene why do we need it
where are we at now and how did we get
here
what are the ongoing challenges and
then i'll pass it over to professor
ragusas who will
take over and cover the technical
aspects of the study
so i did mention that i'm extremely
grateful
to all all our funders and supporters
who have brought us to the stage
so what is dub gene it stands for
detecting
ovarian and endometrial cancer
early using genomics
it is an intrauterine
path test
now for those of you who are not too
familiar with
gynecological cancers i have this
diagram here
which shows the uterus inside the uterus
you have a lining
and that's called the endometrium we
have the tubes
we have the ovaries the what
i will be concentrating on today
is cancers that arise in the endometrium
which is the lining
and what we refer to as ovarian cancer
but ovarian cancer includes fallopian
tube cancer
and what we have come to call primary
peritoneal cancer
but i'll elaborate on this a bit later
why is this important it's important
on two levels on the individual level
it causes great suffering and loss
it affects mothers sisters
daughters wives friends
but if we move back from the individual
level
and look at it from a societal point of
view
it's also a very big deal in the u.s
and this applies not just to the us but
to
most high-income countries of the
90 or so cancers affecting women
ovarian and endometrial cancers rank
third
for the incident cancers that is numbers
of women
affected for cancer related death
and for health care costs so
so it does need our attention
so here are the numbers so here
you can see that in terms of incident
cases
numbers of women affected breast cancer
leads with 26 000
uh 280 268
600 cases but
in terms of deaths
the mortality rate we've made such good
advances with breast cancer
that the mortality rate is only 16
it's still too many but 16 now compare
that
with lung cancer it has a very high
case fatality ratio and so too does
ovarian and
endometrial cancers now the bottom
um table shows
a split between ovarian and uterine
cancer you can say
that here ovarian cancer trumps even
lung cancer that the mortality rate is
very high
62 and
and why is this so
it is so because of one reason and that
is
late stage diagnosis so if you look at
ovarian and endometrial cancer they are
really not
one single entity it's a mixed
bunch of many different types but you
can forget almost
all the other types and remember one
type and that is the high grade serous
cancer
high grade serous cancer of the ovary
happens to be the most common type
it accounts for most of the debts
and unfortunately it's such a bad actor
because
most cases more than 85 percent
are diagnosed in stage 3 and 4 and the
10-year survival is about 20 to 30
we used to present five-year survivals
but we have invested so heavily on the
treatment of these cancers
that you can get women to live can
push the survival to
from we started with three years then it
got went down to four years
five years now we can get them to live a
little longer
but invariably they succumb to it so now
we talk about 10-year survival rates and
that
hasn't budged for over three decades
now with high-grade cirrus cancer of the
endometrium
it's much much rarer most forms of
endometrial cancers are the nicer types
but despite this being rare it accounts
for most of the deaths from endometrial
cancer which means
as vicious and it's vicious because most
of it is diagnosed in late stages
and the 10 year survivals are really
very bad for this
type too
so um as i said the cure rates haven't
changed in 30 years for both these
cancers and that's because of late
diagnosis
now with any solid tumors
if you detect it while it's confined to
the organ
the prognosis is excellent so if we
detect
high grades uh ovarian and endometrial
cancer while it's confined to the
gynecological organs
we can cure this by surgery and if
necessary by adjuvant chemotherapy
one shot and the women remain disease
free
however only 10 percent of women are
detected
in early stages on your
uh right you see that more than
85 percent of ovarian cancers high grade
serous ovarian cancers are detected
after it has spread to vital organs
the bowel liver lungs
neck nodes and once it's spread
to this uh effect all the
it once it affects all these organs you
can't really do surgery to remove all of
these so
you remove what you can and then you are
in just trying to contain the disease
this is something that leyland hartwell
who won the nobel prize for medicine and
physiology in 2001 said he is to be
the president of
the fred hutchinson cancer center in
seattle it costs a
billion dollars to funnel a single
cancer medication through the regulatory
pipeline
for a fraction of that new diagnostics
to spot cancers in their early stages
ultimately
save more lives and this is what we are
trying to do with this
early detection test
so what is it that we have now
really next to nothing for years
we try to figure out
and work on whether ultrasound imaging
of the ovaries
and a blood tumor marker called ca125
would help early detection and really
many many trials including one of the
largest randomized control
trials called the ukc talks
persisted with this for over 15 years
and the final publication was just this
month in in the lancet it showed that
these tests
do not work a screening test
do they work in the symptomatic patients
and we at megal
invested in this in in 2020
to in 2008 we ran a trial
offering this free at the
free of charge quick access to anybody
who had the slightest lighter symptoms
and we found that even when we
cast the net wide even when we made it
easily available
we were unable to detect the disease
in stage one we did find it in
um in a more respectable stage
than if we allowed patients to go
through the usual route
but it still was not good enough to pick
it up in stage one
and and and what our
studies showed the duff project and
again dove stands for
detecting ovarian and endometrial cancer
early
and to refresh your memory we were using
ca125 and endova
for sound scan and what we found is
the reason why these tests don't work
and that is when we first realized
that ovarian cancer is not really
ovarian cancer
about 70 of ovarian cancers start
in the fallopian tube on your right
you see a close-up of the
ovary and the fallopian tube the ovary
is this
pearly white structure you see there and
the fallopian tube is this beautiful
delicate pinky structure that you see
next to the ovary
so the vast majority of high-grade
serous ovarian cancer does
not start in the ovary but starts in
this delicate pinky
structure the fallopian tubes and from
here
it sprays like a aerosol
the cells exfoliate and it's wafted
all over the peritoneal cavity and it's
stuck
under the diaphragm the lower figure on
your right
is you see the top of the liver and the
under surface of the diaphragm
and while the ovary the poor ovary still
looks beautiful and normal
the cells from the cancer cells from the
fallopian tube have
already dislodged and got under
on the surface of the liver and under
surface of the diaphragm
so now you can understand why just
looking at the ovary with imaging
was was missing these cancers
so so now that we realize that we are
barking the wrong tree with looking at
the ovary
we tried to look for other means of
detecting this cancer early
and one of the wonderful success stories
in the history of medicine and in
gynecological cancers
is the pap test for the detection of
ovarian cancer
on this graph you can see that the pap
test
when it was introduced into about the
1960s
the difference it made to the incidence
of cervical cancer
and the death rates from cervical cancer
it you can see it's been steadily
falling since then
and i believe in the next 10 years it
will almost be
non-existent just as we got rid of a
small
pox and to a large extent things like
polio
so and the reason
it's been so successful is we can pick
it up
in the pre-cancer stage when it can be
treated easily
so in countries where the pact test is
universally available free at the point
of
access cervical cancer is not a problem
in canada it's now only the 15th
cause of death in canadian women it used
to be the second higher
cause of death
now so the pap test this on your
left you see a cervix and the pap test
involves
uh scraping the surface of the
cells a surface of the cervix and
putting it on a slide
and the cytopathologist must look for
the cancer cells
in these slides now
this is not going to work
a cytology based test we did many people
did look into this it's not going to
work for the early detection of ovarian
cancer nor for that matter for
endometrial cancer
why because only a tiny you saw how
easily the cells spread from the
fallopian tube
all into the abdomen so to pick it up
early you must pick it up while the
cancer is
tiny and microscopic and what we know
about the fallopian tube is
its reason to exist is
to grab things from the ovary
and push it into the uterus the eggs for
example
so so if we follow its physiological
role
it if there are cancer cells
the first place it will find its way
into
is into the uterine cavity from the
fallopian too
so if you collect something from inside
the uterine cavity and you have
a very high sensitive
sensitivity test not a crude test
looking for the whole cell
on a on a slide but a very high
sensitivity
assay this would work
for early detection of ovarian and
endometrial cancer
and once this idea occurred to uh
me i joined forces with dr vogelstein
from um the johns hopkins
and we evaluated liquid biopsies
from the cervix from inside the uterus
as well as the blood
for to see we could leverage it for the
early detection of ovarian and
endometric cancer
and we published this in science
translational medicine
in 2018 and we established
that yes looking for cancer fragments of
cancer dna
in liquid biopsies it is
by doing this it is possible to detect
these cancers
early and we also establish that
the best method for detecting early
cancers
was not a cervical pap test but going
into the uterus going closer to the
source of the cancer
and for very early for stage three
a combination of blood and cervical pap
test was enough
but for very for the really early stages
you needed an endometrial or
intrauterine pathogen
so having established this we then
tried to improve on the genomic pam test
and ah and
the problem with the study we had
published in the
science in the in science translational
medicine was
the control group we used for
healthy young women now unfortunately if
you're going to offer a screening
test to the population at large you have
to choose the population at
risk and it is women over
45 who have more than 90 percent of
uterine and endometrial cancer and in
this population
unfortunately there's a high background
rate of somatic mutations
and this population also has a high
prevalence of benign diseases like
fibroids endometriosis and these
conditions are also
associated with somatic driver mutation
so the problem then is
to differentiate benign disease
uh no cancers from benign disease and
age-related mutations
so we introduce a new in the
um the work we did with johns hopkins
we had used a binary at uh
classification which is you know
presence of mutation
no mutations but here we
uh in the new phase what we did was
introduce
machine learning to differentiate
cancers
from benign disease and age-related
mutations
we also try to improve on the gene panel
and and it tried to improve our
detection rates with tp53
we introduced um the uh
the braca genes and looked for
genes which were associated with
mismatch repair
now the other thing is you can have a
super duper fantastic result a fantastic
test but if it's difficult for
women in if women do not
take take up these tests easily if it's
difficult for doctors to provide this
then your detection rate is not going to
be uh
good so we also took
this into consideration because the
potential
number of women we have to offer this to
would be very very high close to
about 48 million women um
are potentially eligible and if you say
you're going to offer this test every
two to three years that's
that is still a significant number of
women
so we worked on
coming up with an assay that would be in
the public domain
that would lend itself to automation and
high throughput testing
it would be easy on women and easy for
healthcare
providers
so we worked not just on the assay but
also on a device that would
be uh allow us to collect
the liquid biopsies very very easily
and this is a tiny little beautiful
device that we've come up
with which uh would go into the uterus
and pick up the cells without dislodging
too many of the normal cells
and we also worked on a buffer that
would be stable
at room temperature and
one does not have to go to uh jump
through hoops
to ensure that it reaches a central lab
very soon
goes into it's very tiny and it goes
into uh
the uterus and collects uh the cells
easily
dr uh professor yeah uh the gooses is
going to go into details
of this and again i remind you it's
still in the development
phase it's only a research study still
but we were able in the final
phase of uh phase 2b
by offering it to 402 women in the
context of a study we were able to get a
detection rate of 70
with a specificity of 100
and we are now
offering this in the context of a stage
phase 3 prospective clinical trial
to women in between the age of 45
and 70 in montreal we are able to do
this because we were fortunate
to receive a genomic
applied partnership grant from genome
canada and genome quebec and our
hospital foundation
has also come in uh
and partnered with us to develop this
test and we're very very excited we
started
offering it to women two to uh two weeks
ago and we've already enrolled about 60
women so we expect
this trial to finish quite fast we
intend to recruit
at least 3 600 women between the age of
45 and 70
and we hope to convert it from a
research
test your clinical a grade test
so
um this is for uh people who want to uh
or rather potential patients who want
patients or women who want to access the
test
so um i'm going to end that thank you
very much
um i'm i shall hand over to professor
janis who
who will tell you more about the
technological aspects of this
essay um and and then
be able to answer any questions so thank
you very much indeed for your attention
take care
thank you very much lucy i will now
focus on the dna assay technology
part of the presentation i am miami
zaragozis
from the department of human genetics at
mcgill university
and head of genome sciences at the
mcgill genome center
the development of this assay includes
now several components one is the
collection of samples
from the uterus of the patient
as well as a matching saliva sample
and these two samples are used for dna
extraction
by applying a chemistic fully automated
system
and then the dna extracted
is used for panel sequencing in this
example
using haloplex hs from arjun
with the aim of a detecting jam light
mutations
in the gene panel as well as somatic
mutations
which are then also annotated in terms
of
impact and
pathogenicity further information
that is collected is the age of the
patient and the data
are used for developing
different tools that are make use of
machine learning
to create a classifier and the
classifier
has a binary output either
the sample would be positive for cancer
or negative for cancer and this
information
is generated and it's also put into the
context
of germline variants that are detected
again this could be positive for
variants that are linked
to hereditary risk for these cancers or
no risk so all these
three types of information are generated
using the assay
now the data i'm going to present
are from samples collected in the phase
ii
clinical trial using this essay
it can be separated in two phases and
the main reason for separating them
is the further development and iteration
of the assay
that is being used
at this point i just want to mention
that in the first phase
uh 290 patients were enrolled
in the second phase there were 733 of
them
which allowed for the analysis of 402
patients sample combinations
and as well as 182
from the first part of phase 2.
now the panel that we are using
contained originally 18 genes
linked to endometrial and ovarian
cancers
genes like obviously tp33
p10 but also the full
beam sequence of brca1 and bsca2
to detect variants that could be exposed
to the disease
um as well as kras and then mlh1 and
msh2
in the second part so phase 2b
we included also the full length
sequence of
arid 1a to the panel
as well as hotspot regions
from the genes egfr tall e
not k1 and draft overall we are
capturing
uh now 181
kilo bases in 5477
applicants the other thing that we have
added
is uh assays for 48 snips so what part
of the captures
that allow us to unambiguously
distinguish
between two different samples in order
to identify
any potential mix-up or misa
misalignment between
germline results versus uterine sample
results
so the technology that is used
how to fulfill the following
requirements it has to be
a public in a public domain
it should be automatable through
standard operation
operating procedures and transferable to
medium-sized lab
but also scalable and flexible to
include or eliminate
genes genes as well
as enable germline variant screening
and the inclusion of polymorphic snips
in order to unobviously assign
germline two more type sample pairs
now and here is a graphical
representation
of the haloplase ashley we applied
originally
it required an input between 50 and 70
nanograms
and is being used to
[Music]
capture amplicons that are generated
through one step which includes
enzymatic
digestion of dna hybridization to probes
and then capturing of uniquely barcoded
targets
and pieces followed by pcr amplification
we had published this method originally
a few years ago
in in its application in high
sensitivity sequencing
in the general medical genetics
now the idea behind the unique molecular
barcodes
is the following that you take the reeds
you align them
and you group the reeds according to the
molecular bark of information
so reads with the identical
molecular barcode are grouped together
and then the information
from these reads with the same
molecular barcode is consolidated to one
read
and this it is this consolidation that
leads
to increasing the accuracy accuracy at
which we can detect
through variance and as you can see here
on the right side of the picture
random errors are expected not to be
present within each
sequence within each read while
true variance or is you know originating
from the original dna molecule are
expected
to be present in only so there is a
filtering process
that allows us to increase the accuracy
now the other thing we do is and here is
a presentation
of how we perform downstream filtering
of the data
is that you know you can see here in
green at the top side of the picture
the different amplicons that are being
captured
using the hall of like hs the initial
leads in the middle then these are
grouped
according to barcodes and then
be duplicated to generate consensus
reads
so if we have a read that
has only one barcode and it doesn't it
doesn't appear
again if this back of this does not
appear again it is removed
as well as reads with low quality
barcode sequence are also being removed
the other thing that we do is
because we are capturing these
applicants
in both directions through separate
capture
assays we also want
to include in our analysis
read sequence information from both
strands
so you can see on the top in the green
box
that we have reached that go in both
directions
while if you have at least one antisense
amplicon captured
while in the case where there is no
sense
in antisense sequence information
present
the data are removed from the analysis
the other thing that we look for as a
quality
control of the whole design is that this
homogeneous coverage of the genes
when we sequence deeply and you can see
here data derived
from all genes that we have included in
the assay
and what is the depth of median coverage
that we achieve and you can see that for
the majority of the genes apart from
here so with one exception on the right
with map
one we we have a quite comparable
median coverage
and in this case we aim to be you know
within a thousand
and five thousand x
now what was the result
first of all we did detect germline
variants
so what you can see here
is indeed many of the samples did have
bse1 nbsca2
variant which
had predicted high impact with predicted
high impact
severity you can see that many of them
were stopped gaining gain mutations
deemed to be pathogenic in clean bar
with pathogenic clinvar annotations
so this was quite exciting actually to
be able to
check those rotations
but within the tech mutations in the
scp-1 and bmc
of pathogenic variants in the sa1 and
dc2 but
also in uh mlh1 and msh2
that also justify the inclusion of the
full
sequence of these links
so this was one part so we did detect
german variants and that could increase
the risk
for developing cancers what did we get
in terms of somatic variants
from the interviewer and brush right
samples
so here is a waterfall plot whereby we
line up from top to bottom the genes
that have most mutations
thus the genes have less mutations
detected
in all the samples and the different
types
of cancer samples are
lined up from left to right so in dark
blue
uh on the left side and representing the
majority of our cases
are the endometrial cancers followed by
the ovarian cancers in orange
in the middle but also a significant
number of different behind conditions
that trouble on the right what did we
detect we detect mutations
for the majority of the samples
particularly if these were from the
endometrial cancers
as you can see here most of them
led to the detection of mutations and
underneath the tumor type
you can see the variant allele
frequencies
so basically the endometrial cancers
have the median
variant frequency of about 10 percent
meaning eventually 10 percent of the
sample did include
cells derived from endometrial cancers
while in the ovarian cancers orange
dots in the middle
of the plot
as you can see they we also detect
mutations there
but these were at much lower ambient
frequencies
at the level of approximately
one percent growth slightly higher
now in the benign conditions
we do detect mutations in roughly half
of these as you can see here on the
right part
of the figure but these were
also low alien frequency one and the
median was less
than one percent
so it was lower than absolutely
not detected in ovarian cancers
so you could see you know any a drop
in variant allele frequencies and
associated content of
cancer cells potentially
in these samples from two variant and
then to be nine
more or less the same is true for the
number of mutations for example
we have samples giving us many mutations
in endometrial and less in
you know less so in ovarian cancer
and even less so in living
i have also included here
the stages of the disease that was
diagnosed
as well and what you can see
is that we are quite good actually in
the green
in in detecting early stage degree
disease which is quite important
both for low and high grade
tumors
now this information is then used
into machine learning to develop a
classifier
so what do we do next and this is work
done
by lion the student of professor
sylvia greenwood at maggie university
who is an
expert in this field and we were very
lucky to work with her
the information of variant allele
frequency
and annotation or functional validation
of the mutations
using card using polyphant
and using verb meaning that we include
information related to
consequence conservation in the
particular position
the effect on the amino acid sequence
and predicted protein structure
as well as other functional annotations
is integrated and the interaction
between
these annotations and the variant a
little frequency
is also shown here
so this is also calculated as well as
the number
of mutations so this information it also
goes
into developing a prediction tool
and what we can see is that indeed
when this type of information is
combined
as you can see in this graph whereby
we include information related to the
variant allele frequency which is
on the
y-axis the
curves course of the functional notation
severity
on the z-axis and then the interaction
between these two
on the x-axis so it's a
three-dimensional
picture you can see but what's important
is
the our classifier classifies as cancer
samples in dark
while samples are classified as normal
when saying that the color is light and
what you can see
is actually even if if the sample
uh results in the you know if we detect
mutations at higher level frequencies
top right corner of the graph
for example this plays a key role
as well as whether it has a high gap
score
while samples that have low alien
frequencies and
low verb scores at bottom right corner
are classified as normal and then it is
a matter of
looking at what threshold of a score
from shown here 0.3 to 1
is being applied to differentiate
between cancer and normal samples
if we apply that and we use the score of
0.8 in this case to see whether it is
possible
to distinguish between cancer samples
and benign conditions
you can see here that indeed we have at
a score
of our prediction tool of 0.8
we can actually identify cancer samples
only and the benign conditions shown as
green bars
are excluded because
they produce prediction scores that are
lower than 0.8 in this case so
that gave us hope that actually using
this method
and the combination the information that
we can derive from this assay
that there is a chance to distinguish
benign conditions and answers
now overall we detected using this
particular assay
we detected one or more somatic
mutations
in 84 of all the cases
with cancer versus 45 percent
of the controls and the sensitivity
at high specificity uh of 100 we want
specificity for 100 percent we could say
that
it's possible to have a sensitivity of
about 30
whereby for early stage it could be
81 and late stage 58
using the data that we have
produced now we haven't stopped here
this was
the first step and this is work in
progress
so what we did next is
to try and increase the sensitivity
of our assay and we could increase the
sensitivity of our assay
by increasing the accuracy at which we
can sequence
and the depth of this which we can
sequence
and for this reason we decided
to apply
sequencing technologies that would be
more sensitive
and these were first pioneer for example
by
just a salt as duplex sequencing
which means that if we apply
this approach that contains basically a
more complex
unique unique molecular barcode system
if you can see here a dna fragment at
the top
you know that there is a group of
barcodes called
alpha on the left and beta on the right
and depending on which strand you are
sequencing
you will either have a combination if we
have
alpha with a combination of one so the
purple or
the green followed in in the beta so the
right side of the dna firing if you
as you see of either now
green or purple so
by sorting now the sequences
according to the combination of
particles they have
in conjunction with the alpha or beta
particles
you you can sort them
according to whether they belong to the
top strand or the bottom strand
what is important here in contrast to
the hard flex
assay where we also look for sequences
coming from the top of the bottom strand
in the hand of legs
are saying this could be or this would
be two different
dna molecules while
here we are sequencing the same
dna molecule whereby we can obtain the
sequence from
both of its terms and check whether
the mutation we find is present on both
sides of
the same initial dna molecule
the rest of the
the data analysis is very similar to
what i've shown you before by building
up consensus but this time the consensus
sequence comes from
a combination of top strand and bottom
style sequence
now we applied for this the arduino
select
xt hs version
and there were several reasons for
working with iceland on this
[Music]
one is that we could apply duplex type
sequencing
barcoding system as i've shown before
but also as shown here we want to have
a library preparation method whereby
we can also use the generated libraries
for whole genome sequencing
and this is done by taking analytic work
of the initial library probation phase
as shown here before the probes
are captured as it you know as you know
very very similar to exome or panel
sequencing
using a variety of different vendors
but what is important here is that we
use
the initial library that is generated
containing fragments from the entire
genome
of the sample to perform low pass or
even higher pass whole genome sequencing
so
we split basically the uh the workflow
into a whole genome sequencing part
and a panel sequencing path that is
following
an input is again very long so
it's comparable to haloblades so we use
55 nanograms
of dna
the analysis is very similar to what
i've shown for harplex
basically they read the read pairs but
this time there are four read pairs
they're a library molecule these are
aligned
according to position and then sorted
according to
index structure and then
once they have been shorted in the stand
specific way
the consensus sequence is generated and
filtered for
mutations that are present
or assumed to be present in the original
dna molecule
tyranne wants to sequence a 0.1 to 1
x coverage in this case
which is represents something like 0.323
gigabase of data while for our talent
sequencing because we want the sequence
very deep
we produce about 12 gigabytes per data
per sample
to have a theoretical coverage of 71 000
x and
we use an estimated 15 000 genomes
to achieve that as input
what you can see is that indeed this can
work so using the low pass sequencing
we can detect as in this case
deletions all over the genomes
with green the blue dots are normal
and the red dots above are local
amplifications that we can detect and we
can detect this as just over
at about 1 x coverage
as well as 0.1 x coverage
this of course will depend on the
proportion
of the cells in the sample that are
derived from cancer
but what we want to achieve is even at
low proportions
we want to make sure that we will not
miss the detection of copy number
abnormalities
if there are enough cancer cells
present in the sample in case we did not
detect a mutation
in the genes of our panel
and that seems to work very well this is
an initial assessment
of the source select assay um
again it's a one it's a waterfall plot
with a number of samples that we use to
detect
mutations and indeed there is great
concordance
between helloplex data and should select
data derived from the same
example whereby and this is signified in
the cross
whereby if you look carefully there are
many
quite a number of somatic mutations that
are detected
through the short select assay so indeed
we have
increased the number of mutations we can
detect
what is particularly pleasing is that
when we detect the same mutation which
is in most of the cases
for both samples for both
for both captures from the same sample
there's a very good concordance
of a little frequency um between the
three select captures
and the haloplex captures as you can see
on the left even if we go
to a very early frequency range
of less than 0.01
percent again we do have very good
concolors
between the two assays
using the same sample so that gives us
very good confidence that
we can use the show select now i think
to replace the homoplex assay
and detect low frequency variants
and indeed as shown here
we use this we increase the number of
genes that we are
detecting for example to include genes
like nf1
rb1 r85b
and so on and therefore now we are
detecting even more mutations per sample
in both endometrial cancers and ovarian
cancers and what was particularly
pleasing is that
we are detecting now more mutations
in the ovarian cancers than before we
still detect notations in the denial
conditions
and what we do now is we also look and
we integrate
the copy number information as you can
see here
in pink or lighter or darker
i think you we we see abnormalities and
deploy these
and we can also detect the potential
tumor fraction
below at the bottom of the graph are the
alien frequencies
these are again highest
in the endometrial cancer cases lower in
the ovarian cancer and lowest
[Music]
and what we are trying to do at the
moment is to combine the mutation
protection information as you can see
here in the waterfall plot the first
part of the part above for all types of
conditions
with the copy number information that
you can see at the bottom
which we can classify you know as copy
neutral gain amplification or deletion
and this information is now being used
to develop new classifiers
to distinguish between benign and
cancerous conditions
finally what is the challenge that still
remains
it is it is the challenge that we had
from
the beginning which is that
the the the benign conditions also
containing mutations
and thankfully a
very comprehensive paper was published
out of the sangha institute last year
by muharraptang which looked
at it did a very thorough study to look
at mutations that can arise in normal
endothelium
endometrium and how this compares to
endometriosis carcinoma or cellulose
but the profiles are somewhat different
as we can see here
so what we are looking at at the moment
is to utilize this information to
increase
the success of our classifier
but at least we know that we can expect
if the asset works well
we should be able to detect these
mutations in
normal or benign conditions and our data
agree with that so to conclude
the high sensitivity sequencing using
this assay
allows indeed the detection of very low
frequency mutations
in uterine brush samples
it allows the detection of an omitted
cancer at an early stage
in particular the
application of the source electric hd
assay
in hs4 in combination with low pass full
genome sequencing
does increase the sensitivity of somatic
detection
um and that includes ovarian cancer
cases so we are very excited
about that um
indeed we can confirm that somatic
mutations are also detected in benign
conditions and
this has to be interpreted so our
current work
focuses on differentiating between
benign conditions
and ovarian cancer in particular using a
combination of all the tools that i have
described above both mutation detection
functional notation and copy number
analysis
i finished by thanking my lab
and in particular corey darmont
elizabeth's right
nimara
as well as a particular
team who did a lot of work in
establishing our bioinformatics analysis
pipelines
but also see professor cilia greenwood
and elijah who developed the
the prediction tools
thank you and uh the presentation is now
open
for questions
great dr gilbert doctor produces thanks
very much those were fantastic
presentations
uh we've had a number of questions come
in we won't have time for all of them i
can tell now
but actually uh just maybe to start
with one which would i think probably go
to
both of you and that is how do you
balance sensitivity versus specificity
in the w test
uh can i uh can you please lucy go ahead
okay
okay so uh this is really the challenge
because we do know that we can increase
the sensitivity
almost up to uh 90 95 percent
but then uh the specificity
would be poor
and the problem with any test
which we cannot corroborate
so for example if you take something
like a mammogram
uh it doesn't matter if the specificity
is low
because if you have a lump in the breast
you can always do a biopsy
of course nobody likes the biopsy but
at least you don't have to take the
breast off you can do do
you can do a biopsy so
with with a test in which you can
corroborate
without a terribly dangerous procedure
it doesn't matter if the specificity is
not very high
in the dub gene test because
the only way to corroborate a
a positive uh finding would be
to major surgery to remove the uterus
tubes and ovaries
that's why we we have a very hard
task ahead of us and we have to set this
specificity at almost 100 percent
that is why we were prepared to accept
a lower sensitivity so
so so to answer your question
it depends on the site
and what is available to corroborate
uh positive results so in something in
which
major surgery is needed we have to set
this
sense a specificity very very high so we
will
not tolerate even a 1
false positive i hope that answered your
question
yes i think that was that was a a
a great uh great response and yes it's
always a balance isn't it
there's no bright line um and then to
continue
on that theme how do you see the test
developing
in order to increase both the accuracy
and sensitivity
so um so here we have we are almost
walking on a tight rope
a tightrope so we do not want to
give people a false uh positive test and
then subject them to major surgery
so we've kept the specificity at almost
near 100
but equally we do not want to tell
somebody
uh you don't think you have a cancer and
then six months later they're diagnosed
with
cancer so what we have done is we are
not compromising on the specificity
but then we are working extremely hard
to improve the sensitivity so
i we believe that we've got
very high sensitivity for endometrial
cancer
but we are continuing to improve the
assay
by picking up uh p15
tp53 mutations we are introducing
copy number changes to increase
the sensitivity for
high grade serous ovarian cancer which
really is our nemesis
okay great and then a question came in
and i think this would
be for dr ragusas about whether you used
a consensus reference genome
and how that was derived and then
follow-on question there on
uh sequence depth that you would
recommend
yes we we good question so we did use
the
we do use the reference genome and in
this particular case
we use 1819
or grc37 so because these are the
versions
that are being used by ageland
to generate the design for the assets we
are using
so yes it is the the reference genome
that
you can find in the university of santa
cruz
genome browser for example in terms of
depth of sequence as shown
we can we have gone down to 71 000
sort of leads per base coverage
the recommendation is to seek
at least one thousand-fold net coverage
[Music]
but this really depends on
the type of assay that is being used
i don't think we have fully exploited
the potential
of the so select xth s
[Music]
but we have i think we are quite close
to that but at the moment we use 70 000
volt
coverage of the genome that allows us to
detect
about 0.05 variantly frequencies
okay great thanks for that and uh
then an additional um
follow-up question which that
[Music]
listener have is uh what the percent cut
off of
uh for your baf is in the pipeline
and on turnaround time from sample to
a report the
the cutoff point at the moment is at
0.05
but we are working towards
decreasing that even further
aim of turnaround time is
three weeks it really depends on
the number of samples that are being
used and the
the reporting structure that is being
put in place but our aim is a three-week
turnaround time it can be done faster
even but this is what we are aiming for
at this point
okay great and i think
um another question came in that uh
if i can um sort of compress
a little bit uh it's a great
presentation basically
um are you looking at any altered
mrna expression levels i i don't think
i'm distorting that question by
uh condensing it down to that
and the what we do is you know looking
at the question
yes we do as shown uh at the end towards
the end of the presentation
uh we are working towards incorporating
copy number
uh alterations into our
assay so yes we do look now at copy
number
alterations and feed that into
the asset development so
rna expression we are not doing because
this would be a completely different
essay
it may be possible to do that but at the
moment for
due to the assay design the assay is
based
on dna in order to be able
to obtain germline the full germline
sequence
of the genes that we want to interrogate
and look for germline variants
independent
of the levels of gene expression in the
tissue that is being found
okay great and then maybe one final
question
um on the genes in your panel
why not include all hereditary ovarian
cancer genes
in the panel
it's another okay good question we
theoretically we could have included all
of them
um they are obviously the more you
include
the the returns are diminishing
what we try to do is to keep some of the
most important genes like brca1 and
brca2
and fully sequence those for any
predisposing
variant so we try to balance
basically the the genes where we expect
to have
uh variants that's predisposed to
disease
versus the genes that would contain
somatic
mutations that we need to identify and
look for cancer drivers or signs
of cancer or cancer signatures
it's a compromise sure
sure
okay uh that was fantastic um
dr gilbert dr recluses would either of
you have any final comments for the
audience
no thank you i'd like to thank the
organizers thank you so much for giving
us this
opportunity to present our work um
and for the support to help us develop
a test which we believe will change our
lives
thank you also like to thank the
organizers
and if there are further questions from
the audience this
can be sent particularly related to the
essay itself
and we would be happy to answer it
asap thank you okay thank you thank you
fantastic well thank you both for your
time and
for this really i think really important
research
i also want to thank uh lab roots for
for uh for hosting uh this
educational event and most especially
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and and the great discussion and and
engagement
um for those questions we didn't get a
chance to answer today
um or that will be submitted if you want
to go back and watch it on demand
we will try and address those via the
contact information
that you gave us when you've registered
this webinar will be available to view
on demand
elaborates will alert you via email when
it's ready for replay
we encourage you to share that with your
colleagues who might not have been able
to log on today's
live event and with that i will
wish you well and until next time
goodbye